franchement je vous encourage le voir
c'est un super film c'est un quartier et
une cité qui a envie de s'en sortir et
par tous les moyens
certains d'une manière maladroite
d'autres d'une manière plus plus
acharnés et imaginons nous enlève notre
moyen de survie le rêve quoi il ya un
vrai talent de mise en scène ya un vrai
talent direction d'acteurs il commence
ce qui est génial c'est qu'à une
justesse tout le temps ça sonne juste
tout le temps est ici mis un polar ni
une comédie c'est les 2 en même temps et
on passe un superbe montre donc toute sa
splendeur
puis les pompiers pompent plus confuse
d'union plat planteurs combien temps va
vous aider en fasse piquer pour une
forme qu'on veut stocker à francfort les
coeurs toquer à la pop aura l'âge d'or 8
et 15 coupure record du nombre de
déménagements à la fin il a même quitté
coria plus pied corps du tendon publie
de risques en force